週刊金融日記、第七百四十二号です。
タイトルは「エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円、分割後七万円を超えます」となっています。
ほかにも、「日米が協調介入で円高誘導」、「香港で美味しいポルトガル料理のお店」、「人間ドックなどが情弱ビジネスだということを再掲載」など、さまざまな話題をお届けします。
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
ぼちぼち香港でやっていますが、あいかわらず、そこまで南国らしい暑さでもないんですよね。
しかし、ことしの香港は雨が多くて、香港天文台によると、二千二十六年七月の総雨量は七百九十・三ミリメートルに達したそうです。
これは平年値の三百八十五・八ミリメートルの二倍以上ということになっていて、一八八四年に香港天文台が観測を始めてから、二番目に多い七月になったみたいです。
ちなみに、七月の半導体株の下落も記録的でしたが、香港の雨量も記録的だったんですね。
ほんと、やれやれです。
[EN]●HK sees wettest July since 1997 with more rain coming[/EN]
[EN]HK-sees-wettest-July-since-1997-with-more-rain-coming-2026-08-01[/EN]
どうして雨が多いことを嘆いているのかというと、週末に美味しいポルトガル料理のレストランに行きまして、そこでポルトガルのグリーンワインを五千円くらいで買ってきたんですよ。
普段は安いニュージーランドのワインなんですけど、それを紙袋に入れて持ち歩いていたところ、途中で雨が降りまして、紙袋が濡れてしまったんです。
それで、うちの玄関に入る直前になって、とうとう底が抜けて落としてしまい、ワインを割ってしまいました。
それで、自分でガラスの破片を片付けたりしていました。
香港だと、中華系のレストランではワインを安く持ち込めるお店が多いですし、中国本土だと、基本的にどのレストランも持ち込みが無料なんですよね。
どうも、そういう規則があるみたいで、なのでワインをよく持ち歩いています。
でも、二千十九年から香港に住んでいて、ワインを落として割ったのは今回が初めてです。
ま、確率的にいずれはこういうこともあるだろうなと思っていたところではあるんですが、本当に、とほほという気分ですね。
話は変わりますが、週末は美味しいポルトガル料理のレストランに行ってきました。
それから、Xサブスク（月三ドル）についてですが、アップルやグーグルに手数料をもっていかれてしまうスマホのXアプリからではなくて、宇宙開発を応援する意味でも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXをウェブブラウザで開いて、そこから直接申し込んでいただけると助かります。
また、ついさきほど、キオクシアの兄弟企業であるサンディスクの決算前エーアイ分析レポートもアップしました。
今週も、読者の皆さんから興味深い投稿がいくつも届いています。
見どころは、次のとおりです。
- 波乱の七月半導体相場・過去のSOX指数暴落から回復までの時間を分析
- アラフォー既婚ですが、不倫関係の彼女に別れを切り出されました
- 所長は大腸がん検診は受けていますか
- ブラウザからXサブスクさせていただき、メモリ工場のエクセルに驚愕しました
それでは、今週もよろしくお願いします。
ここからは、「エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円、分割後七万円を超えます」についてです。
半導体やアメリカのテック企業の決算が相次いで発表され、株価も乱高下して、とても慌ただしい一週間になりました。
今週のマーケットコーナーにも書きましたが、エーアイを使って決算分析レポートを怒涛の勢いで生成していました。
月三ドルのXサブスクのほうにアップしていますので、世界の株式投資に興味がある方はぜひ見てみてください。
エーアイ半導体株が下落しても、アメリカのハイパースケーラーはエーアイデータセンターへの投資をどんどん加速させていますし、日米が協調介入で円高誘導、イラン週末戦争はまたTACOか、といった感じです。
（金融日記ウィークリー　二千二十六年七月二十四日から七月三十一日）
また、Xサブスクのほうでは、世界の主要メモリ工場すべてをカバーする、ボトムアップ型の供給予測モデルをアップしました。
今週は気合いを入れて、『メモリ半導体株の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか』という三部作の最終回でも書こうかなと思っています。
ディーラムとHBM、そしてナンドフラッシュについて、世界工場ごとの供給や、製品別需要のボトムアップ予測モデル（Xサブスク）もそうですが、
『週刊金融日記　第七百三十九号　メモリ半導体株（マイクロン、エスケー ハイニックス、サムスン、キオクシア）の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか　需要編』
『週刊金融日記　第七百四十号　メモリ半導体株（マイクロン、エスケー ハイニックス、サムスン、キオクシア）の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか　供給編』
こうしたものも書いています。
そんなふうにしていたら、半導体株がさらに乱高下、というか暴落してきたり、最後にはまた切り返してきたりと、相場はまさに波乱万丈の展開になってきています。
僕は、グローバルな証券会社の自己売買部門やヘッジファンドのことについては、それなりに詳しいんです。
いまでもXでゆるくつながっている人たちは、ヘッジファンド関係者が多いので、このエーアイ半導体株の暴落の裏で何が起きていたかは、おおよそ分かっています。
こういう相場ネタは、何よりも鮮度がたいせつですので、今週はまず、この背後で何が起こっていたのかを書いておこうと思いました。
また読者の方からもタイムリーな投稿が週末に届きました。
僕は基本的にメルマガの読者投稿のカットオフをだいたい水曜日ぐらいに設定していまして、水曜日までに届いたものは、その週末のメルマガにだいたい載ります。
投稿が多い週には、緊急性のない投稿は後回しにして、投稿が少ない週のメルマガに載せて平準化したりしているので、「スルーされているのかな」と思っている方も、気長に待っていてください。
そして、こういう相場に関する読者投稿も、生鮮食品と同じで、掲載が一週間遅れるだけで、ほとんど価値がなくなってしまうんですよね。
なので、今週号に掲載して、これも冒頭に持ってきました。
続いて、読者の方からの投稿をご紹介します。
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
波乱の七月半導体相場・過去のSOX指数暴落から回復までの時間を分析
藤沢先生
お世話になります、ミッシェルです。
先週号では、投稿を冒頭に掲載していただきありがとうございます。
何だか昔を思い出して、懐かしい気持ちになりました。
先週はマイクロソフト、メタ、アマゾン、そしてエスケー ハイニックスにサムスン、そして僕たちのキオクシアと、重要な決算が次々と発表されて、怒涛の一週間が終わるのと同時に、波乱の七月相場が終わりました。
第七百四十一号に掲載された僕の投稿のとおり、僕は確信を持ってエスケー ハイニックスを決算発表前に仕込みましたが、読みが外れて株価は大きく下落しました。
いったん損切りしつつも、長期的な視点には自信があったので金額を増やし、百三十五ドル（ADR）で再エントリーしました。
トータルでは手数料の分だけ損したことになりますが、画面上から含み損が消えるという心理的な効果があります、笑。
どこまで下がるか心配していたキオクシアは、四万円を割り込みましたね。
僕も、さすがに心配しましたが、逆に仕込みどきだと思って、キオクシアはすでに保有しているので、同じく暴落していた共同事業パートナーのSanDiskも千百ドルでエントリーしました。
ちなみに二千二十五年はエスアンドピー500で上昇率ナンバーワンでした。
半導体株の乱高下には慣れている僕でも、この一週間はまるでジェットコースターのようで、毎日しびれながら冷や汗をかいていました。
この七月、半導体株の動きを代表する指数であるSOX指数は、月間でマイナス二十パーセント下げました。
僕のポートフォリオというか全財産の動きはSOXとかなり連動しているんですが、二千年以降でSOXが月間で二十パーセント以上下げたのが何回あったか調べてみたところ、以下のとおり八回でした。
ChatGPTやClaudeではうまくまとめられなくて、Geminiは適当な感じだったんですが、なんとKIMI K3がまとめてくれました。
暴落したときは、だいたい二千年のITバブル崩壊と、二千八年の世界金融危機のときでした。
SOX指数が月間で下落率マイナス二十パーセントを超えたケースは、こうなっています。
二千年九月、下落率マイナス二十六・一四パーセント（前月末終値 千百五十二・四十二）
回復日は二千十七年九月十八日（終値 千百六十・九十）／期間 六千二百二十七日（約十七年）
備考：ITバブル崩壊後の長期低迷
二千年十一月、下落率マイナス二十七・六一パーセント（前月末終値 七百四十一・四十七）
回復日は二千年十一月六日（終値 七百四十五・四十一）／期間 六日
備考：月内に一時回復（ただし月末はふたたび下落）
二千一年二月、下落率マイナス二十六・〇八パーセント（前月末終値 七百三十一・八十四）
回復日は二千十五年三月二日（終値 七百三十四・五十一）／期間 五千百四十三日（約十四年）
備考：ITバブル崩壊後の長期低迷
二千一年九月、下落率マイナス三十三・五九パーセント（前月末終値 五百六十二・四十五）
回復日は二千一年十二月五日（終値 五百八十五・五十二）／期間 九十六日（約三か月）
備考：九・一一テロ後の急速回復
二千二年九月、下落率マイナス二十・六四パーセント（前月末終値 三百・〇四）
回復日は二千二年九月十一日（終値 三百一・六一）／期間 十二日
備考：月内に一時回復（ただし月末はふたたび下落）
二千二年十二月、下落率マイナス二十二・五七パーセント（前月末終値 三百七十三・三十五）
回復日は二千二年十二月二日（終値 三百七十五・〇六）／期間三日
備考：月内に一時回復（ただし月末はふたたび下落）
ここからは、二〇〇八年十月の下落率とその回復についてお話ししますね。
二〇〇八年十月は、下落率がマイナス二十一・九七パーセントとなりました。
前月末の終値が三百六・七四でした。
そして、回復したのは二〇〇九年八月三日で、この日の終値が三百六・八七。
期間は三百七日、およそ十か月かかりました。
この下落と回復は、リーマンショック後の動きなんです。
そして、二〇二六年七月のデータです。
下落率はマイナス二十・六一パーセントで、前月末の終値は一万四千二百四十六・九六でしたが、現時点では回復していません。
回復日は未定、終値もまだ戻っていないという状況です。
ちなみに、これは二〇二六年七月三十一日時点での話となります。
情報の出どころは、KIMI K3 です。
さて、今回の二〇二六年は年始からものすごいペースで株価が上昇していたことを考えると、二六年六月末時点でSOX指数が年初来プラス九十八・七パーセントだったことからも、この程度の調整（下落）が起きるのは当然とも言えるでしょう。
ちなみに、先ほどお話ししたリストのうち、前年末比で株価が上がっていたのは、二〇〇〇年九月と二〇〇一年二月だけなんです。
二〇〇〇年九月は前年末比プラス六十三・七パーセント、そして二〇〇一年二月はプラス二十七パーセントでした。
それ以外は、年明けから株価が下がっている状況での大きな暴落だったということです。
なお、〇一年二月も実質的には下げ局面でした。
ここで、今回のエーアイ半導体株の暴落がITバブル崩壊型となるのか、それともリーマンショック型になるのか、どうなるのかが気になるところですね。
個人的な体験としては、ここ三年くらいの半導体投資で「この決算内容で値が下がるのはおかしいだろう」と思ったタイミングで仕込んでおくと、しばらくして気が付いたらかなり株価が上昇している、というパターンが続いていました。
特に、暴落時は本当に仕込み時なんですよね。
最近でいうと、二五年四月のトランプ関税ショックがそれにあたります。
このときSOXは月内最安値下落率でマイナス十六・六パーセントまで下がったんです。
その体感としては、今回の暴落と非常に似ている感じがあります。
ちなみに私はこのとき、キオクシアを千七百円で仕込んでいます。
さすがに、その後何十倍になったのは想定外でしたが。
メモリ株は今はセンチメント、つまり雰囲気がよくないですが、しじょうのセンチメントは本当に変わりやすいものです。
たとえば、女の人の機嫌みたいなものですね。
このペースで利益を出していけば、しじょうはいずれ「やはりメモリだ！
スーパーサイクルだ！
！
」と騒ぎ出すものだと確信しています。
そういえば、藤沢先生のXサブスクで配布されたあのディーラム・ナンドフラッシュ工場のエクセル資料、あれは本当にすごかったです。
とても参考になりました。
もしあれを調査会社から買おうとしたら、ふつうに百万円以上しますからね。
藤沢先生はこの歴史的な相場でポジションを取り、その熱い思いを記録に残しておきたいということで、私も熱く語らせていただきました。
この歴史的なエーアイ相場の先行きは、本当にしじょうの神のみぞ知るといったところですが、きっと二年後どころか一年も経たないうちに、この二六年七月の暴落は、二五年四月と同じように、絶好の押し目買いのチャンスだったと振り返ることになるでしょう。
週刊金融日記の読者の皆さんと一緒に、そのリターンをぜひ享受できればと願っています。
キオクシアが最高値の十一万二千七百円を更新した暁には、最高値更新記念として「Can you store data？
」というフレーズをエーアイに歌わせて、それをYouTubeにアップしてくださいね！
さいごに、バフェット大先生の言葉でこの投稿を締めたいと思います。
[EN]In the short run, the market is a voting machine, but in the long run, it is a weighing machine.[/EN]
しじょうというのは短期的には人気投票ですけど、長期では企業の本質的な価値を測る秤（はかり）であるということなんですね。
ミッシェル
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
続いて、編集部注釈です。
さて、何が起こっていたのかというと、実はとてもシンプルなことなんです。
しじょうではこういった出来事が二年か三年に一回くらいは起こっています。
もっと小さなものなら、さらに頻繁に発生しています。
ある程度損失が出ると、強制的にポジションを解消しなければならない投資家たちがいます。
ヘッジファンドの株式ロング・ショート（L/S）ポジションなども、そのショートサイドも含めて、非常に似通った銘柄に集中していました。
ヘッジファンドの株式L/Sだと、このような相場環境でエーアイ半導体株を買っていないとバカだと思われるので、当然みんな買いに入っていました。
また、韓国の個人投資家も同様で、信用取引でエーアイ半導体株をロングしていました。
そんななか、何かのきっかけで込み合ったポジションが逆に動き始めると、誰かがロスカットに追い込まれます。
すると、そのロスカットの売り圧力で下がっている株はさらに下がり、ショートサイドで仕掛けていた銘柄はもっと上昇します。
次のロスカットを誘発し、こうした雪崩のような展開がガンガン起こっていくわけです。
また、これを嗅ぎつけた短期トレーダーが「まだまだロスカットの連鎖が続きそうだ」と考え、そこにポジションを取りにいきます。
こうして、雪崩がさらに加速していきました。
せんしゅうはXでも、ヘッジファンドの株式L/Sが大変なことになっていそうな声が聞こえていたんです。
悲鳴が聞こえてきたというわけですね。
そして、その象徴的なニュースがこの話です。
もともと、ヘッジファンドのヘッジというのは、しじょうが下がっている時でも安定して儲けるための仕組みです。
ただし、上昇時にはインデックスファンドに比べて出遅れることも多いのですが。
今回のエーアイファンドはレバレッジを効かせて、エーアイ銘柄をとても大きくロングしていました。
当然、これまでは圧倒的なパフォーマンスを誇っていたわけです。
エーアイ特化ファンド『シチュエーショナル・アウェアネス』は、七月に六十七パーセントの下落ということになりました。
こういうのは証券会社の自己売買やヘッジファンドの経験がある方なら分かると思いますが、本当に二年か三年に一回くらいの頻度である、よくある話なんですよね。
マネジャーに詰められて、トレーダーがポジションを損切りさせられている様子が目に浮かびます。
そして、たまたまこうしたタイミングでリスクを取れる余裕が残っていると、現物株をロングしてきた投資家なら、待機させてあった現金で、ロスカット連鎖がそろそろ終わるころに気合いを入れて逆張りすることで、それなりの利益を得られる、そんなケースが非常に多いんです。
ここまで話すと、僕の見方がミッシェルさんとほぼ同じ、というのがお分かりいただけると思います。
ちなみに、せんしゅう号でもお伝えした通り、僕はエーアイ革命に気がつくのが遅れて、メモリー半導体株に乗ったのもだいぶ後発になってしまいました。
でも、自分がポジションを取って、このメルマガで怒涛の半導体特集を始めたら、とんでもないスピードでメモリ半導体や他のエーアイ半導体関連の株が爆上げして、それはそれで僕も儲かったし、執筆者としても絶好のタイミングで嬉しかったんです。
ただ一方で、これだけ急騰すると半導体特集を読んで、自分で分析してから買おうと考えていた普通の読者にとっては、すでにすっ高値になってしまったなあ、と思ったでしょうし、僕自身ももっとポジションを増やしたかったのに増やしづらくなってしまったのは、ちょっと残念だったんですよね。
しかし、そのキオクシア株などが二倍以上に上がった後、また半値以下まで戻ってきてくれました。
まあ、たしかにふくみ益は消え、多少含み損も出ましたが、これから控えめに見積もってもあと二年か三年は続くであろうエーアイ革命――つまり怒涛のエーアイ大相場のまえに、またポジションを積み増すチャンスが巡ってきてくれて、僕としてはとても喜んでいるところです。
これからのエーアイ大相場が二年か三年続くとしたら、ポジションを積む期間に株価が低迷するのは、むしろ好都合なんですよね。
特に、ちょっと割高すぎて僕は買えなかったメモリ半導体以外の半導体装置関連の株なんかも、今回の暴落で買いやすくなりました。
まるで夏のバーゲンセール期間中に、たくさん仕入れるような感覚です！
とりあえず、さきほどKOSPIのイーティーエフを買っておきました。
さて、最後に、日本のエーアイ半導体の主役ともいえるキオクシアについて、僕の目標株価を書いておきます。
こういった半導体企業の利益をボトムアップで予測しているプロの証券アナリストたちによるコンセンサス予想EPSは、だいたいこんな感じです。
二〇二七年三月期で、約一万円ぐらい。
二〇二八年三月期で、約一万三千円ぐらい。
二〇二九年三月期で、約一万五千円ぐらい。
僕は非常に保守的なので、かなり控えめに一万四千円ぐらいのEPSとします。
そこに、これまた保守的にピーイー比は十五倍を想定して、目標株価は一万四千円×十五倍で二十一万円ぐらいと考えています。
さらに、キオクシア株は十月一日に一株を三株に株式分割するので、二十一万円は分割後ならちょうど七万円という計算ですね。
ということで、年末までに二十一万円ぐらい、そして分割後は七万円ぐらいを見積もっています。
でも、こんなエーアイ革命の真っ只中にいる会社のピーイー比十五倍は、さすがに保守的すぎるかな、とも思います。
六月には猛スピードで、自分の目の前を通り過ぎていった「エーアイ革命」という名の特急列車ですが、乗り遅れた……とあきらめかけていた投資家の皆さんの前に、今、奇跡のような光景が広がっているんです。
しじょうの神様は、時にこんな粋な計らいを見せてくれるものですね。
ヘッジファンドと信用フル活用の個人投資家のロスカット連鎖パニックという気まぐれのおかげで、本来なら停まるはずのなかった夏の各駅停車の駅に、このエーアイ革命の特別列車が急停車してくれたというわけです。
発車のベルが鳴り終わるその前に、この時代が用意してくれた最高の切符を手に取って、みなさんも一緒にエーアイ革命列車に飛び乗りましょう！
投資は自己責任でお願いします。
タイトルは、「週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号 エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円、分割後七万円を超えます。
」といった感じで始まります。
日米が協調介入で円高を誘導し、香港で美味しいポルトガル料理のお店の話や、人間ドックなどが情弱ビジネスだということを再掲載しています。
これは夜間飛行のパート三分の五ですね。
もし儲かったら僕のメルマガに感謝しましょう。
そして、もし損した場合は自己責任なので大いに反省してください。
続いて、こんしゅうのマーケットのコーナーです。
2026年七月二十四日から七月三十一日の一週間のパフォーマンスをみていきます。
[EN]TOPIX:      4003.30, -0.2% (1w), +16.8% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225: 64362.02, -0.4% (1w), +27.9% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:     7489.72, +1.0% (1w),  +9.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:     160.18, -2.2% (1w),  +2.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:     181.49, -2.6% (1w),  -1.2% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 84.67, -5.2% (1w), +47.5% (YTD)[/EN]
エーアイ半導体株は下落したものの、アメリカでははいぱーすけーらーがエーアイデータセンターへの投資を加速しています。
そして、日米が協調介入で円高を誘導し、イラン週末戦争はまたTACOか、という話も出てきています。
これは金融日記Weekly、二千二十六年七月二十四日から三十一日の内容です。
せんしゅう、つまり七月二十四日から三十一日にかけての株式しじょうは、韓国発のエーアイ半導体株のパニック売りと、アメリカのハイパースケーラーの好決算を受けた急反発が交錯して、極めて値動きの荒い一週間となりました。
週間ではTOPIXが零点二パーセント、日経平均が零点四パーセントそれぞれ下落したいっぽう、マイクロソフトとアマゾンの決算の支えもあってS&P500は一パーセント上昇しました。
ドル円は日本の金融当局の介入があり、週末にかけて円高が進みました。
日経平均は二十八日に四パーセント近く下げたあと、三十一日には四パーセント高と急反発しており、一週間での小幅な下げという数字からは想像できないほどの激しい相場でした。
今回のエーアイ半導体株の下落は、企業の業績悪化ではまったくなく、混み合っていたポジションが雪崩のように崩壊した、そんな形です。
エーアイ関連株を買い上がってきたヘッジファンドのアンワインドに加えて、個人投資家の信用取引や単一株レバレッジイーティーエフの強制決済が重なりました。
とくに、レバレッジが大量に残っていた韓国しじょうが下落を先導し、二十八日にはコスピが十一パーセント安、サムスン電子が十三パーセント安、エスケーハイニックスが十五パーセント安と急落しました。
さらに、元オープンエーアイの研究者が率いるエーアイ特化ファンド、「シチュエーショナル・アウェアネス」も、エーアイ株への集中投資とレバレッジが裏目に出て、七月に六十七パーセントも下落し、保有上場株の大半をシタデルに売却せざるを得なくなったんです。
業績自体は悪化どころか、予想の鈍化さえ起きていませんが、とにかくポジションが壊れてしまったんですね。
メモリ半導体企業の決算は凄まじいものとなっています。
エスケーハイニックスの第二四半期の営業利益は過去最高の六十兆五千億ウォン、営業利益率は七十六パーセントに達しました。
HBM4の量産出荷も始まっています。
サムスン電子もメモリ事業が過去最高の売上高と営業利益を更新し、半導体部門だけで八十九兆二千億ウォンの営業利益を稼ぎました。
キオクシアも四月から六月期の売上収益が一兆七千六百七十一億円、営業利益一兆二千七百億円となり、生成エーアイ向けデータセンター需要による販売価格の大幅上昇を報告しています。
数字だけを見れば本当に驚くべき決算です。
ただ、これほどの利益成長はしじょうにもある程度予想されていて、好決算だけでは強制決済による売りを止められませんでした。
キオクシアの経営陣は、現在の株価がファンダメンタルから著しく乖離していると考え、三ヶ月で最大八千億円にものぼる巨額の自社株買いを発表しました。
一方で、半導体を購入する側の企業決算も、エーアイデータセンター投資が減速するどころか、さらに加速していることを示しています。
マイクロソフトはアジュールが四十三パーセント成長し、顧客需要が利用可能な計算能力を上回っていると説明しました。
四半期の設備投資は四百十億ドルに達しており、二年間で全体の計算能力を約二倍にする計画を立てています。
メタも二千二十六年の設備投資計画を千三百億から千四百五十億ドルへ引き上げ、アマゾンはエーダブリューエスが三十七パーセント成長したことを受けて、年間設備投資計画を二千億ドルから二千二百億ドルへ増額しました。
はいぱーすけーらーがエーアイ投資の回収を心配して設備投資を削る、そんな不安が一部の、あまりエーアイや半導体に詳しくないしじょう関係者のあいだで広がっていましたが、実態はむしろ逆で、需要に供給が追いつかないために、さらに巨額の資本を投入しているという状況です。
メモリ企業では過去最高益が続き、その顧客であるはいぱーすけーらーも設備投資をさらに増やしています。
こうした事実を踏まえると、直近の暴落をエーアイバブルの崩壊の始まりと解釈するのは、あまりにも滑稽です。
短期的には、信用買いの整理やファンドの換金売りがどこまで残っているのかは分かりませんし、株価もファンダメンタルズを無視して乱高下するでしょう。
しかし、筆者はメモリ株をはじめとするエーアイ半導体関連株への強気な見方を全く変えるつもりはありません。
次に為替しじょうについてです。
日米当局による事実上の協調介入というサプライズがありました。
日本政府は大規模な円買い介入を行い、さらにアメリカ財務省はニューヨーク連銀を通じて円買いに動いたと報じられ、ドル円は一時百五十七円台まで急落しました。
正式な共同発表は週明けになると見られていますが、実現すれば円買い方向の日米協調介入としては実に十五年ぶりです。
ベッセント財務長官の机の上に置かれた円買い介入のメモまで、ロイター記者のカメラに写り込むという猿芝居も含めて、日米両政府は投機的な円売りを牽制する姿勢をしじょうに強く見せつけました。
そして、恒例となったトランプ大統領の「週末イラン戦争」についてですが、今回もTACOになりそうです。
イランのエネルギー施設への大規模攻撃が検討されていたものの、トランプ大統領は週末、ホルムズ海峡の全面再開などを巡る合意に時間を与えるとして、新たな攻撃をいったん見送りました。
もっとも、イラン側はアメリカに停戦を求めたとの説明を否定していて、正式な合意は成立していません。
ミサイルや迎撃弾の消耗、また湾岸諸国のアメリカ軍基地やエネルギー施設への報復リスクを考えると、軍事的な制約からもTACOらざるを得ない面がありそうです。
原油価格はひとまず下がりましたが、中東の供給リスクが消えたわけではありません。
ここからは今週の主なマクロイベントについてです。
主なものとしては、三日のアメリカISM製造業景気指数、五日のISM非製造業景気指数、そして七日のアメリカ雇用統計となります。
企業決算としては四日のAMDが注目され、アメリカ巨大テックの決算ラッシュはほぼ締めくくられそうです。
日本でもトヨタ、三菱重工、ソフトバンクグループ、任天堂、レーザーテックなど重要な企業の決算が続きますので、為替介入後の円相場と合わせて、しじょうの焦点は日本企業に移るでしょう。
続いて、アジア半導体株が急落し、エーアイ投資と中国勢との競争が警戒されています。
韓国株の急落がアメリカ半導体株にも波及し、アジア発の「パニック売り」はなぜ繰り返されるのかという話もあります。
エーアイ特化ファンド、「シチュエーショナル・アウェアネス」は七月に六十七パーセント下落しました。
元オープンエーアイの研究者が運用するファンドで、エーアイ株による損失が拡大し、シタデルが保有株を取得する事態となりました。
また、政府と日銀が円買いの為替介入を行い、一時は百五十七円台まで円が高騰しました。
ニューヨーク連銀がレートチェックをおこなっています。
アメリカ当局も円買いに介入したのではないかとされ、ニューヨーク市場の円は百五十七円台前半に急伸しました。
円安是正で日米の足並みがそろいました。
日米が十五年ぶりに協調介入を実施することで思惑が一致し、片山財務相が三日に表明しています。
ベッセント長官のデスクの上に置かれた「円買い介入」のメモまでがロイターに報じられるという猿芝居まで飛び出しました。
また、トランプ氏はイランのエネルギー施設への「大規模攻撃」の見送りを表明しました。
戦争犯罪となる可能性もあり、政権内で反対意見が出たとのことです。
トランプ氏は対イラン攻撃をいったん中止しましたが、ただし、迅速な合意成立が条件となっています。
恒例のイラン週末戦争でも、トランプ大統領が再びTACOとなりました。
ミサイルの枯渇や、予測されるGCC諸国のアメリカ軍基地へのイランの報復攻撃など、軍事的な制約でTACOせざるを得ない状況とも言えそうです。
[EN]★Xサブスク（3USD/月）で、SK hynix、Samsung、Microsoft、Meta、Samsung、[/EN]
アップル、アマゾン、キオクシア、エーエムディーなど、エーアイによる決算分析レポートや、エーアイバブルの現在位置について、筆者とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読を希望される方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリからではなく、スマートフォンやパソコンのブラウザからXのサイトを開いて、そこで直接サブスクリプションを登録し、ついでにイーロン・マスクさんの宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
このサブスクでは、ディーラムプラスHBMやナンドフラッシュの世界工場別供給、製品別需要のボトムアップ予測モデル（Xサブスク）、それから、SK hynix 二千二十六年第二四半期決算、過去最高利益と供給制約の現在地（Xサブスク）、マイクロソフト二千二十六年第四四半期決算のクラウド成長とエーアイ投資のバランスシート（Xサブスク）、メタの二千二十六年第二四半期決算、千二百五十億から千四百五十億ドルのキャップエックスの行方（Xサブスク）、サムスン電子二千二十六年第二四半期決算のHBM4と長期供給契約・増産計画の全貌（Xサブスク）、アップル二千二十六年第三四半期決算のメモリ価格急騰下での業績とこんごの見通し（Xサブスク）、アマゾン二千二十六年第二四半期決算、二千億ドルのエーアイ投資の行方（Xサブスク）、二千二十七年三月期第一四半期キオクシア決算、営業利益日本一への軌跡（Xサブスク）、そしてエーエムディー二千二十六年第二四半期決算、エージェントエーアイは高いピーイー比を正当化できるか（Xサブスク）といった情報が読めます。
最後に、八月三日月曜日の予定ですが、日本の七月新車販売台数、そして日本の七月軽自動車新車販売台数の発表があります。
タイトルは「週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号 エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円、分割後七万円を超えます。
日米が協調介入で円高誘導、香港で美味しいポルトガル料理のお店、人間ドックなどが情弱ビジネスだということを再掲載、他【夜間飛行】（パートフォーファイブ）」です。
まずは経済指標や決算スケジュールのご案内です。
アメリカの六月建設支出、アメリカ七月アイエスエム製造業景気指数、中国七月RatingDog製造業購買担当者景気指数、いわゆるピーエムアイです。
決算は三菱ユーエフジェイ、三菱商事、伊藤忠、丸紅、LINEヤフー、大和証券、協和キリン、JALほかです。
続いて八月四日火曜日の主な予定です。
日本では七月マネタリーベース、十年国債入札、アメリカは六月の貿易収支、六月の製造業受注、六月雇用動態調査、いわゆるジョルツ求人件数が発表されます。
決算はトヨタ、三井物産、三菱重工、ソフトバンク、ダイキン、イビデン、日本製鉄、横河電機、ヤマハ発動機、住友化学、日清食品、エイエムディー、[EN]Caterpillar、Pfizer、他[/EN]です。
続いて八月五日水曜日です。
日銀金融政策決定会合の議事要旨、六月毎月勤労統計、アメリカでは七月ADP雇用統計、七月アイエスエム非製造業景気指数が発表されます。
主な決算はアステラス製薬、スズキ、アイエイチアイ、鹿島、花王、ローム、太陽誘電、JR西日本、資生、[EN]堂、明治、三井化学、メルカリ、Eli Lilly、Uber、Walt Disney、Sandisk、他[/EN]です。
八月六日木曜日は、日本七月都心オフィス空室率、三十年国債入札が予定されています。
決算はソフトバンクグループ、エヌティーティー、任天堂、味の素、富士フイルム、レーザーテク、住友不動産、レゾナック、古河電工、[EN]KOKUSAI、東レ、サントリーBF、SUMCO、楽天銀行、東急不動産[/EN]などです。
八月七日金曜日です。
六月家計調査、六月景気動向指数、アメリカ七月雇用統計、六月しょうひ者信用残高、中国七月貿易収支などが予定されています。
主な決算はリクルート、ケーディーディーアイ、フジクラ、日本郵政、第一生命、インペックス、三井不動産、ENEOS、ニッペイント、川崎重工、キリン、商船三井、三井金属、出光興産、ゼンショーなどです。
そして、八月八日土曜日と九日日曜日には、中国七月しょうひ者物価指数、いわゆるシーピーアイと七月生産者物価指数、ピー・ピー・アイが発表されます。
続いて、ここからは「ブログではいえないお店」についてです。
香港で美味しいポルトガル料理のお店のご紹介です。
今は二千二十六年四月から六月までの決算シーズンでバタバタしていて、飲食不毛の地だとディスられている品川駅周辺のまあまあ美味しいレストランを少しずつまとめているところなんですが、まだうまくまとめきれていなくて、本当にすみません。
そんな中で、週末に、隠れ家的で看板も出ていないポルトガル料理のレストランに行ってきたんですが、かなり美味しかったので、忘れないうちに書いておきたいと思います。
こういったお店って、あとで書こうと思ってもなかなか思い出せなかったりしますもんね。
場所はしゃんわん、Sheung Wan の住宅地、急勾配のエリアにひっそりと佇んでいます。
急勾配なので店内は自然とロフトみたいな造りになっていて、上のテーブルから下が見下ろせる感じです。
ポルトガルのワインがたくさん置いてあります。
もともとはポルトガルから食材やワインを輸入しているポルトガル人オーナーが、「自分の故郷の美味しいものを香港のゆうじんや同郷の人たちに振る舞いたい」という気持ちで始めたお店だそうです。
口コミで広まって、今のようになったみたいですね。
ドリンクメニューはなくて、お酒は相談しながらおまかせになります。
そこが香港らしい「プライベートキッチン」、いわゆる私房菜スタイルなんだと思います。
看板もない隠れ家っぽい雰囲気で、宣伝もほとんどせず、親密な空間をたいせつにしている感じのお店です。
ちなみに、歩いてすぐのところに普通のデリみたいな系列店もあるようですが、今回は完全予約制のプライベートルームの方に行きました。
[EN]■Casa do Vasco - Private Room[/EN]
[EN]1/F, 23 New Street, Sheung Wan, Hong Kong[/EN]
+八五二 9167 7571
予算は夜ならワインをガブガブ飲んでひとり千香港ドルくらい、だいたい約二万円でしょうか。
料理はどれもポルトガル人オーナーの故郷の本格的な家庭の味です。
ポルトガルから上質なオリーブオイルや新鮮な海鮮を空輸しているだけあって、素材の味を活かした優しい味付け。
マカオで食べたポルトガル料理と比べても、どれも美味しかったです。
やっぱりマカオのポルトガル料理は観光客向けになってるので、マカオではフカヒレを食べなきゃダメですね、なんて笑ってしまいました。
『週刊金融日記　第七百三十一号　フカヒレはなぜ香港ではなくマカオで安くて美味しいのか調べたら驚愕した』という話もありましたね。
名物は、表面や底がカリカリお焦げになっている「ポルトガル風ダックライス」、それからワインのおつまみに最高な「バカリャウ」、いわゆる干し鱈のコロッケなどです。
五人くらいで前もって予約すれば、レイタオン、Leitao、つまり子豚の丸焼きが出てくるそうなので、今度人数を揃えて行ってみようと思いました。
海老はミディアムレアで本当に美味しかったですね。
名物のダックご飯はお焦げがクリスピーで最高ですし、ハーフチキンもなかなか美味しかったですよ。
デザートはエッグタルトです。
となりのテーブルでは誕生日祝いをしていて、ケーキをおすそ分けしてもらいました。
そのあとで、お店のスタッフがデザートワインをどんどん出してくれて、本当に私房菜らしい、アットホームでもてなしてくれる雰囲気が良かったですね。
続いて、ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談のコーナーです。
アラフォー既婚ですが、不倫関係の彼女に別れを切り出されました、というご相談です。
藤沢先生とメルマガにはかれこれ十年以上お世話になっています。
さいきんのメルマガでよく話題になる社会情勢や経済の話にはなかなかついていけず、今でも恋愛で悩み続けているアラフォー男です。
誰にも相談できず、ただ不安を吐き出すような投稿で申し訳ありません。
私は家庭があって、妻とこどもがいます。
加えて、セックスできる関係の女友達が二千二十五年の時点で三人いましたが、すべて既婚者だということは開示済みでした。
ところが二千二十六年になってから一人、また一人と離れていき、理由はともにアラサーで「彼氏ができた」という、まあ当然かもしれないですが、最後の一人とも関係が終わりそうな状態です。
この子は既婚でこどもがいない、いわゆる本命です。
向こうも「夫の子供は欲しいと思えない」と言っていて、お互いこれから先のことも考えて愛し合ってきました。
それが、デート中の何気ない会話から「こんごを考えたい」と言われました。
これまでも年に一、二回はそういう不穏な時期があったんですが、今回はこのまま関係そのものが終わるかもしれない雰囲気です。
不倫関係を続けるのが辛くなってしまったのか、年齢的に出産を考え出したのか、理由は考えれば色々あるんですが、心の拠り所としてかなり頼りにしていたこともあって、人生のモチベーションが保てなくなりそうです。
自分のやってきたこと全部が間違っていたのではないかとも考えてしまいます。
今も一日に数回LINEをする程度ですが、向こうも辛そうで、彼女とはまだ話す機会があるはずですが、そのときに何を話せばいいのか、こんご自分が何をしてあげられるのか分からないです。
長くなってしまいましたが、彼女のために自分が何ができるのか、また、自分のモチベーション維持について、その他全体を通して何かアドバイスがあれば頂きたいと思い、相談させてもらいました。
よろしくお願いします。
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
やっぱり三人いたのが最後のひとりになって、非モテコミット、いわゆるひとりに執着してしまったのが良くなかったと思います。
また新しく二人くらい、見つけましょう。
それから、人生に彩りを添えたいなら、女性だけでなくキオクシア株なんか持つのも良いかもしれませんよ。
Good Luck!
続いて「所長は大腸がん検診は受けていますか？
」というご質問です。
最低限の人間ドックで十分というお考えだと思うのですが、大腸がん検診は受けていますか？
最近は松本人志さんや東野圭吾さんなど、大腸がんになった有名人の話も続いたので、大腸内視鏡検査を受けているのか、もし受けていなければそのメリット・デメリットについてどう考えていらっしゃるのかお伺いしたいです。
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
医学的には、人間ドックそのものが、ほとんど情弱ビジネスですよ。
なぜ情弱ビジネスかについては、このメルマガにはお医者さんや医学研究者の読者も多いので、すでに過去に書き尽くしました。
がん検診について、健康な状態で「念のために」と受ける検査で、本当に効果があるとされているもの、つまり、検査をした方がしないよりも寿命の期待値が伸びると医学的・疫学的にしっかり分かっているものというのは驚くほど少なく、年齢によっても変わります。
若い時はどんながん検診でもやればやるほど損なんです。
これは検査費用の問題じゃないですよ。
そして、基本的にはおせっかいな日本の場合、有効性が認められているものは自治体の無料の検診で全部カバーできています。
大腸内視鏡検査は、数少ない本当に有効な検査のひとつなので、日本の自治体から案内が来ているならやった方がいいと思いますが、それにしてもメリットは微々たるものなので、中高年ならやった方がいい、というのが僕の見解です。
ただし、香港ではそういった微々たる公衆衛生上の改善のために無料で提供していないので、僕は面倒なのでやっていません（笑）。
ちなみに、香港の平均寿命は日本より長いですよ。
なぜ人間ドックが意味がないか、むしろ（極めて微小ですが）有害とすら言えるのか、ごくわずかながん検診しか医学的に有効性が認められていないのかについては、ちょっと難しい話になるので、バックナンバーを読んでみてください。
忙しい方は、第三百八十五号と第六百八号だけでも目を通してみるといいでしょう。
この話題に関しては、『週刊金融日記 第三百八十二号 がん検診は意外と有害だった』、『週刊金融日記 第三百八十四号 がん検診の情報ソース』、『週刊金融日記 第三百八十五号 正しいがん検診とがん治療はとても簡単だった』、そして『週刊金融日記 第六百八号 がん検診についてはこれが"答え"です』も参考にしてみてください。
タイトルは、「週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号、エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円、分割後七万円を超えます、日米が協調介入で円高誘導、香港で美味しいポルトガル料理のお店、人間ドックなどが情弱ビジネスだということを再掲載、その他、夜間飛行の第五パートです。
」
ここからは、いただいた感想についてです。
「ブラウザからエックスサブスクさせていただき、メモリ工場のエクセルに驚愕しました。
」
藤沢所長、いつもお世話になっております。
さっそくブラウザからエックスのウェブを開き、三ドル課金してメモリ工場のエクセルをダウンロードさせていただきました。
ディーラムとHBM、ナンドフラッシュの世界工場別供給、製品別需要ボトムアップ予測モデル、エックスサブスのファイルを開いた瞬間、SamsungからCXMTまでびっしり網羅された工場リストや、年間平均ウェハー投入能力、HBM向けウェハー配分、といったマニアックすぎる変数の数々に、私のポンコツな脳のメモリが即座にスタックオーバーフローしてしまい、クラッシュしました。
調査会社が数百万円で売るレベルの資料を、月三ドルでバラまいてしまう所長の狂気を感じました。
それにしても、きょうもキオクシア株が下がり、とうとう三万円台でなかなか辛いです。
私の買値は……聞かないでください。
とりあえず、このエクセルをお守り代わりにしつつ、二千二十八年の答え合わせの日まで、日々の変動は気にせずに半導体株をガチホしようと思います。
こんごともよろしくお願いします。
七月三十日、編集注です。
続いて、ふじさわかずきさんの回答です。
正直、僕はメモリ半導体株についてはぜんぜん心配していません。
冒頭のコラムで書きましたが、少なくとも、二千二十八年ぐらいまでは持つし、それまでどんどん買い増していこうと思っていたので、これからの大エーアイ相場の前に、調整してくれて助かっているぐらいですわ。
ということで、キオクシアのベアバージョンの歌でも口ずさんで、本業に打ち込んでください。
キオクシアの歌のベアバージョンです。
「愛、すなわちエーアイは勝つ」（原曲はKANさん）
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。